GRACIE STONE: Scratchwork is a
intelligent and collaborative
whiteboard tool.
Our goal as a
company is definitely
to make education
collaboration a bit easier.
It's really important to us
not to outdate handwriting.
Rather, we want to
acknowledge that that's
the way people think and
rather than combating
that in the digital age,
embrace it and take that
into another platform to
allow for all of the added
capabilities that a
computer can offer.
GREG GAUTHIER: So you
start with your whiteboard
and then you can enter items
onto the board as you'd like.
You draw on it with your mouse.
You can draw with an attached tablet.
One of the things that makes us
different from the competition
is you can take your
drawings on pen and paper
and hold it up to a webcam
and take a picture of it
and make them
digital objects, then
you can rearrange
and move around
to create just the idea you
were thinking of in your head.
I teach
multi-variable calculus,
and one of the things I do
is I look for problems that I
can then explain in class.
I'm able to take
these ideas here,
put them into digital
objects so I can present them
on the day of class arranged
just the way I like,
and so that my
students have notes
that they can follow when they
are studying for their exams.
GREG GAUTHIER: The summer
accelerator program
is a 10-week program.
Each participant gets
a stipend as well as
housing for the summer, as
well as co-working space
here in the eHub.
So we have a boot camp at
the beginning of the program
involving how do
you run a business.
And it can be a
really busy time.
We had seven teams working
in the eHub this summer.
RACHEL YEE: The
co-founders of Scratchwork
were nice enough to create a
little finance project for me
to learn in Python.
And I learned how to do some
financial modeling, which
was really cool that I was able
to contribute in a real way,
and also learned a
skill set at the same time.
I felt that even my
experience compared
to what I learned
about startups in class
were completely different doing it
and physically being there.
GRACIE STONE: I would definitely
say that the biggest thing is
access to mentors that you
definitely would not otherwise
have.
They come from
various backgrounds,
and that's what's so powerful
about it is they've been VCs.
They've been
entrepreneurs themselves.
They started things.
They've seen things fail.
They've seen things succeed.
And we made such
different decisions,
and I think far
better ones than we
would have been able to make
without access to any of them.
GREG GAUTHIER: There's a thing
on the wall here in the Keller
Center.
We have all the logos that the
6 years to date of the summer
accelerator teams,
and we're really
hoping to add
ourselves as an example
so that people
who are at Princeton
can look to the
Keller Center to see
that their entrepreneurship
really is a viable option
and that there are
resources available.
RACHEL YEE: I think
the Keller Center does
an incredible job of exposing
students to real-life scenarios
and companies.
I think that it gives us a
larger perspective on the world
and how we as individuals
and even as Princeton alumni
can have a tangible impact
through the businesses
or nonprofits that we create.